okay so i'm going to talk about uh well
obviously threshold phenomenal and
actually uh
really it's not combinatorial but it is
combinatorics but it's a
really random random structures and
if i'm really honest it's it's random
graphs um
so i'm going to talk about
instances where there's a basically the
sudden change in
structure and
um and all the sudden emergence of
various properties
and i'm not going to really do i'm not
going to i'm trying to cover
as many
cases of this is like not as well i'm
trying to cover as many cases
of this phenomenon as i can think of
um and so i'm
sometimes it will be
a bit more technical than it should be
but most of most of the time it's it's
not going to be very technical and
most of the time would be correct i
think
okay
okay so i mean this was a list of things
um
so just to make sure that we're all on
on the same page uh
okay this is our well this is a graph
okay so uh i assume everybody really
knows what a graph is
um
but
i have to
i have to say this and place a graph
vertices and edges
and there's a complete graph this is the
um this is a graph with uh every
possible edge in there with six vertices
okay
yeah so a lot of times you'll you'll
know what i've you've seen this all this
stuff before um i was told this was open
to everybody so i i
i wasn't sure who everybody was so um i
may have to sort of
say things that you really know okay so
so i'm going to talk about a lot of the
stuff it's about random graphs
so in this context uh what's a random
graph
well we'll actually be talking about
something which i'll call the random
graph process
so we start with we
we expose that um e1 up to en capital n
is a random ordering
of the edges of the complete graph so
you take all the possible edges of the
complete graph put them in a random
order and you add them one by one
and after you've added m edges we'll
have a graph which i'll call gm
and
and what we will find is that this
graph has um there are certain
properties which appear very suddenly
and this is really what the the talk is
supposed to be about
okay so in the beginning
ah there are no edges
and we add the edges one by one
and what we find is in the early stages
of this process
uh all the edges are will tend to be uh
disjoint from each other
and what am i what do i mean by the
early stages what i mean as provided we
only add
little o of the square root of n so what
we're assuming here always is we're
saying n is very large n is growing to
infinity
and i'm assuming then that the number of
edges divided by n 10 root n defense
tends to zero
and i'm saying that usually usually it
looks like this what i mean by usually i
mean that the probability that any pair
of edges intersect tends to zero as n
tends to infinite infinity so i'm saying
this this picture occurs with high
probability and the whole subject is
about figuring out figuring out what
happens with high probability that's
what we're interested in
well this time interestingly okay
so uh if m is little of square root n
they're all disjoint whereas
if
you go a little bit further on if you
make it grow the number of edges say
square root of n times log n then you'll
almost surely
say almost surely but with high
probability you will see a pair of edges
that share a common neighbor so this is
basically what's called this is
basically the birthday paradox
so after about square root in
edges have appeared the property of
having a compound we call this thing a
component with two edges
happens with high probability
so then you go on a little bit more add
a few more edges and in fact if you add
round about and so ends square root n is
now replaced by n to the two thirds you
start seeing these
other little objects
okay i mean if you have a sort of a
fanciful imagination
you might think that what's happening is
we started with single-celled creatures
the single-celled edges and as time
progresses we get more and more
complicated creatures appearing
these little trees are the complicated
uh creatures
okay and uh okay so
that's just the first that's the just
the very early stage of this thing
so this process was um studied by a very
famous couple erdos and renyi uh they
wrote this paper on the evolution of
random graphs so there we were talking
about how does this as we add these
edges at random how does this thing
evolve
so there they are that's here dash
that's rennie and you notice the number
of citations is quite high
at least uh that according to google
okay so uh so i've drawn a picture so
here the thing is here's a table
um
so there's the paper the number of edges
this is the structure well this should
be gm or gnm it's the same it's the same
graph so
little old square root n because
isolated edges and vertices
once you go beyond square root n
you'll get isolated edges vertices
powers of length two
when you get up to n to the two thirds
you get components of this form you get
mostly isolated vertices the next thing
you get these isolated edges
and then after that you'll get
um
powers of length two and then you get
parts of length three and this other
thing
okay and and there's more of these than
those more of these than those more of
these than those
and in general um if you replace two
thirds by nine tenths you'll get things
with nine or ten
uh 10 vertices
pretty clear uh picture
okay
okay so now so now we
we got to
we got here so what happens if the
number of edges is
of linear size
okay
so um
suppose you have a
what happened
now suppose you have a um
edges or a half cn edges or you've had
if and c is less than one so you have
less than half and edges so random edges
so what does it look like it's mainly
trees but you get a few components
which have which is a tree plus an edge
but by and large it's a it's mainly
trees
uh and they're all small water log in in
size uh so this is basically a forest
okay
and then it is sudden jump
in structure so if you've got so here c
is less than one
and here c is bigger than one and
suddenly you've got this giant component
of size gamma of cn
and the rest is just trees
so so it's sort of
sudden change from see less than one
small component see bigger than one you
get this unique giant component
and of course uh you have to ask
yourself what happens at c exactly one
and this is much more complicated so i
won't say much more about it the
interesting thing is that the size of
the largest component is something
around n to the two thirds somewhere
between log n
and n and it's of order n to the two
thirds okay um as i say it's much more
complicated
ah
so there was some other stuff oh yeah so
sorry darshan rini called this in the in
this 1960 paper they said this was the
most interesting part of the paper
and they called this the double jump
okay so you jump from less than one one
greater than one they call this the
double jump in size the giant and uh
nowadays we talk about the phase
transition
and okay so here we've got it a unique
giant of size so question is where does
this gamma of c come from
well
we can relate this to something called a
branching process it's a gamma of c is
the probability that a certain thing
called a branching process
with this
distribution
uh is the probability that this doesn't
go extinct so i'll just show you a sort
of reasoning why that should be
uh
so anyway there's a tip here is the um
the airdos rini graph as they call it uh
with uh m c n over two where c is
strictly bigger than one so you see
there's this giant component and all the
rest is just little trees
okay
so what's a branching process so it's
just a tree a randomly grown tree
um
and uh
i think that this thing called the
golden watson process was introduced as
a model of um
the survival of the family name of the
british aristocracy
so smith would give rise to two smiths
this smith didn't have any kids and this
smith had two kids and so on okay so the
and so this branching process was
supposed to model um
so i mean i'm not sure that smith had a
press on number of kids but um
if he was a uh a vertex in the
erdos rini uh model he would give rise
to this number of kids
so that's the point so if the expected
number of descendants of a vertex is
bigger than one then there's a problem
positive probability that the tree is
infinite or it gets large
and so for us gamma of c
is
is this positive probability that the
tree is large
so if you look at this vertex
coming and you look at this neighborhood
it looks like one of these galton watson
trees
and the probability that it's large is
gamma of c
so the expected number of vertices that
see a large tree is n times gamma of c
and if they see a large tree they all
sort of join together into this giant
component which sort of explains why
you'll get a giant component of size
gamma of c times n and you can make that
proof precise
if you want to
okay ah so if you go on a bit longer um
you'll see so that was
ah
the early stages of the process and the
process continues right m goes from one
up to n choose two you might ask
yourself more questions
when is this happen when does that
happen this is what a lot of the um
study of random graphs is about when
these things happen and and by now
this has been going for
what 50 years now or 50 57 years to be
precise uh we found out a lot
i said in fact the earliest paypal of
airdromini was the proof that the graph
becomes
uh connected
round about
uh a half n log n edges
so once the graph has half end log n
edges then the probability is connected
is this very pr is very really quite
precise
and so we look at uh in some sense he's
supposed to draw this picture which says
um what's the probability it's connected
as the number of edges grows and it sort
of shoots up quite fast
and so around about this point is what's
called the threshold
okay so that's what we're looking for
we're threshold hunters right we're
looking for the thresholds for various
properties
okay
okay so now i'm going to talk about a
couple of basic properties of graphs uh
the first property is related to things
called matchings so a matching in a
graph is just a set of edges which don't
share a common vertex so the edges
disjoint edges
and the graph is perfect if every vertex
is covered so this is a perfect matching
okay so you might ask yourself does this
graph have a perfect matching
ah another question that's often asked
is about things called hamilton cycles
so here's a graph
the question is does it have a hamilton
cycle well a hamilton cycle is a cycle
which goes through each vertex once once
only and there you have the
that's a hamilton cycle right the red is
a hamilton cycle so they might ask the
question does my random graph have a
hamilton cycle
okay
okay so let's
go through some basic questions so
here's the same thing so let so we say
the mk so we're adding the edges one by
one
and we ask ourselves when does the
minimum degree become at least k
they call that mk so look at the edges
the vertices the edges
and when every vertex sees at least k
edges that's mk
so the results that we've seen so far
can be
rephrased like this but the erdos really
actually proved
um as soon as every vertex sees at least
one edge
the graph becomes connected so you re
you realize that the b connected
every vertex must see at least one edge
so in principle m1 could come before
connectivity but in this uh in this game
m1 and
connectivity are at the same time
and then a bit late say seven years
later
you might say when does it have a
perfect matching well to have a perfect
matching every vertex has to see at
least one edge
okay and so
say certainly you don't get a perfect
matching before m1 but they prove that
you actually do at m1 for a hamilton
cycle it's a cycle so every vertex
should have degree at least two
okay so of course you know the answer
that's m2
and this took a bit longer actually so
they in the 1960 paper they asked for
um
when does it have a hamilton
cycle or a hamilton path
and they were working quite hard on this
between here and here they were
producing
a reasonable number of papers well
reasonable by most people but um the
reasonable number of papers on uh random
graphs but it did take what 25 years to
uh to actually sort this one out and
there are lots of partial results in
between
okay so that's the basic stuff about um
random graphs so uh
generally speaking so we we if you're a
graph theorist you talk about properties
of graphs if you're random graph
theories you say when does a random
graph have this property
and
so we're interested in the m such that
the probability the graph has the
property is small if you are um
well this is this value this is the
threshold value right so if you if
you're a lot less than the threshold you
shouldn't have it within with with the
probability you have is very small
and if you're much above the threshold
you should have it and so the question
is you give these properties and you
want to figure out what this tau p p is
fifa property
okay so lots of research has gone into
finding these things and there are now
lots and lots of results on this
so the first book on the subject was by
bola bash
and now it's in its second edition
uh it's quite difficult to read but
it's a very good book obviously but it's
quite difficult to read um and this is a
bit uh this is a newer book um also i
would say a little bit difficult to read
and so ma michael and i michal and i
sort of wrote a more elementary book
which um
i mean i think
i should say well no i shouldn't say
anything it's like i'm trying to make
you buy the book okay uh
right so let's go in next
skip okay so now i should also mention
directed graphs
um so
the question is what are you going to so
directly graph is a graph you put
orientations on the edges
uh so now we suppose we start we do the
same thing we add directed edges one by
one
and so let's dm be the first m directed
edges
and now instead of looking at the size
of
components you okay so we don't look at
so if it's directed we want these things
called strong components
so what's a strong component a strong
component is just a
a maximal set of vertices such that you
can get from one to the other on along a
directed path
so you can't talk about vertices you're
talking about components you talk about
strong components so very natural
question is
um
what's the size of the strong components
in a random directed graph okay so this
problem was
okay so suppose the m is some constant
times n
and that
z
be the size of the largest strong
component
and so this is a result of dick
1990
and he proved that uh this is less than
one
but basically you're the the giant the
the components are tiny
but uh what's interesting is that if c
is bigger than one the size of the
largest strong component is the square
of the size of the largest compo well
is this gamma c but it's squared here
so you might say y gamma c of y gamma c
squared
and the answer is quite simple
um
because
in the uh
in the undirected case you couldn't see
that they're roughly gamma c n vertices
that can reach
many other vertices this is what the
giant component is in the graph there
are gamma c n vertices that can reach
many other vertices and this and and
that works in the directed case and
similarly there are gamma c and vertices
that can be reached by many others so if
i'm a vertex the chance i can see lots
of other vertices is gamma c and the
chance that lots can see me is gamma c
so the chance i have both properties is
gamma c squared
which is not a proof obviously but it
tells you
what's going to happen
okay so now i'm going to go through a
few more models
uh i'm looking for these thresholds
okay so another model has been studied
reasonably well is um you fix the degree
sequence
so you call that so gd you fix a degree
sequence and gd
will be a random graph chosen uniformly
from all graphs with this degree
sequence
and
okay
so anyway um so malloy and reid worked
out a threshold for this so you work out
some function of the degrees
and then it has a giant component
if and only if basically this lambda is
bigger than one less than one there's no
giant it's small and lambda greater than
one
ah
so again you get this sudden change in
some sense right
and it's a and again the proof is
something about branching processes
essentially lambda is the expected
number of uh
neighbors in a branching process and so
it's bigger than one so you get a giant
okay so try to make something okay now
what's next
all right then okay
uh now i know less about this but um
you can imagine
uh if i wanted to look at a simple graph
so what we did we took the complete
graph and we took a random subgraph of
the complete graph
so i think physicists are quite
interested in random sub-graphs of
more structured graphs lattices
and so here we can consider
this is called percolation
and you consider the infinite lattice z
to the d
and in bond percolation
you delete an edge independently
with probability one minus p
and you get this infinite graph right so
you can keep the a keep the vertices
keep the edges we probably and then you
get that
and this was introduced um this is
supposed to be as a mark well
not it's a model of
liquids percolating through a porous
material so through some strut i mean
it's a very simplified model obviously
um
okay so here's a picture of it so this
is supposed to be
suppose it's a three-dimensional lattice
in there and the water is percolating
through
ah
anyway so uh so one of the first results
on this was you so here you've got an
infinite graph
and you basically want the question is
when does the origin lie in an infinite
component or when does there an infinite
component
and
uh i thought i just mentioned this so p
less than half the probability is zero
and p greater than a half the
probability is one so this
um
notion of random graphs does have um
does appear in
uh
or they're infinite random graphs okay
but i don't know i know very little
about this stuff but um
but what i do know
there are many natural questions but
it's very difficult it's more difficult
to get answers to squeeze the answers
out of here than it is uh for the uh
complete graph random subject of the
complete graph for example i don't think
the uh if you instead of deleting edges
if you delete vertices i don't think
it's known this the result like this
isn't known as far as i know
so it's much much more difficult i mean
it would seem you know the the lattice
two-dimensional lattice is a really
simple graph right
and so
it should be easy but
apparently not
okay so what's next
oh okay um
so i'm now we're looking for
uh
another um
instance of
transitions
okay
so uh so we're going to look at
colorings of graph the chromatic number
of a graph
so a proper k current will graph you
just give every vertex a color and um
and if the colors are different
it's a proper one
the chromatic number is the smallest
number so that's the giza proper k
coloring
okay so there is a value dk
now actually um
this is not quite true i when i wrote
this slide
uh i got um somehow there's a reason
very recent result
um
is
everything i say now has been recorded
okay very good
okay
so um
so people have been looking at the
following
so we have a random graph
and we look at the set of proper
colorings of this random graph
so here this so we have the random graph
but as another graph called gamma which
has a vertex for every proper coloring
and an edge
if the two colorings only differ at a
single vertex
okay so
and now we and now so we look at
gamma as we add edges
and we're looking at k coloring so k is
fixed here
and so initially
there are many many many uh colorings
and they're all connected together so
this gamma will be connected
so
okay
and then
this particular
then all of a sudden as as you add edges
you get fewer and fewer colorings
so ah
you still got this giant ball here but
now some of this stuff breaks off
okay and this is supposed to a lot of
this the study here is inspired by
um
physical physics notions
okay okay so there's this called
reconstruction
our athens about k log k
okay
and then if you go up to this point
which is about twice that
right the whole thing sort of breaks up
into lots lots and lots
of ex well this and each of these blobs
has an exponential number of um
colorings in it
and they're all far apart
and then there's a few little ones i
suppose
and then i think you go down to just a
constant number of these things this i'm
a bit hazy on
and then
there's nothing
okay
and i'll mention something later on but
the idea here is that algorithms trying
to find these colorings they can work up
to this point
because this is a just a massive blob
here but they sort of break down round
about this point in fact so uh if you go
to k-log well
let's yeah
so
this is about k log k
and algorithms
are for finding colorings that we know
of
only seem to work up to about
r d is k log k
what i'm talking about
yeah that's one
because after that there's not enough of
them or actually it's this business
they're all sort of yeah you've got to
get lucky at the beginning to find these
things and that's that seems to be
difficult
but next
okay so it's a slight change of our
topic but only very slight
so
we already so we've seen then that if um
the gm if you have m is are there some
brackets missing here so if the number
of edges is
rough is is constant times n but this
constant is strictly bigger than
a half
then with high probability you get this
giant component
okay so if i added
what it point five zero zero zero zero
zero one
and random edges i would see a linear
size component with high probability the
probability i didn't see one will be
exponentially small
so uh
dimitri demetrius accoliopters ask the
following question
so suppose instead of just so what we're
getting is one edge at a time and you
can't do anything about it you get the
edge and then you wait till you've got
about n over two and there you see the
giant
so but what if you've got
two of them
and you can pick one
can you delay the appearance of a giant
component i mean and can you do that
significantly beyond a half n
in other words what would you mean by
significantly
can you delay it
to beyond
some constant times n where the constant
is bigger than a half
okay so you're doing these so you
okay so the answer was yes
yes okay you know can you just smoke
these make these small changes
you nudge the random process into some
extremely unlikely position
okay so the answer is yes so tom bowman
and i um
found it was possible and it's a simple
rule very simple rule so um
so suppose
that your edges are e1 and e2
and what you do is you look at the first
edge
and if uh
if x1 that should have been a one so if
x1 and y1 are currently isolated
you take that edge
otherwise you take the second one
okay so you're trying to avoid this
giant right so you see this you see
these two vertices coming along and
they're both isolated so if you take
those that edge all you do is create a
small component with two vertices in it
whereas if
if you
took the other one you might create a
bigger one anyway that enabled us you
could take that to 0.58 n
so um
right so that sort of started a sort of
a whole well
a whole slew of um
yeah our proof was combinatorial
and uh the proofs since then have been
more based on differential equations
and you get a better and and
you get a better estimate of 0.58
and then actually you can also if you i
mean if you like having a giant
component uh you're going to speed it up
so if you are
i can't remember what the actual rule
was but they were able to speed up two
point three eight four i think we must
take the other one okay if they're both
isolated you take the other one and that
was enough to speed it up to 0.385 n
right
and
there's a sort of small um a sub area of
random graphs which studies these
processes and there's still quite a lot
of open questions about this process
ah
what is this
okay i'll skip this
because i don't want to go on forever
ah
anyway but use differential equations in
this thing and are
very simple differential equations right
okay
okay so now um
we come to this thing called explosive
percolation right explosive percolation
so what do we mean by supposed explosive
perforation so if you're trying to think
of a rule that would very quickly give
you a giant component so you've got
these two edges that come along which
one should you choose i mean you don't
know what's going to see in the future
um
so i don't think it's bola bash but well
it says bowler batch that must have been
him
you pick
so you take the two edges and you take
the size of the component
in
this one has this one is in a component
of a certain size this one is in a
component of a certain size you multiply
those two together
and call that the product rule
okay so so if the product is big it sort
of says that the new component you
create is going to be big
okay
yeah so you're trying to avoid that
so you choose the one with the smallest
arm you choose the one with the smallest
i thought there should be a1b but but in
mind so you choose the one with the
smallest um
product that's the product rule
and
well it's that's not been properly
analyzed to analyze this properly
properly
you come up with differential equations
and you come up with an unbounded number
of them and
for some reason that's difficult an
unbounded number of differential
equations can't be solved
okay
but anyway in spite of that
um
acquioters
d'souza and spencer did some experiments
with this process
and
they
tried it for quite large graphs six
times a million six million vertices
and they suggested
that um
the size of the giant component
jumped from square root n
to half n
in
this number of steps this is what their
experiments were telling them okay so
they called this explosive
percolation
right
and this got into science this
paper
and i remember tom had to write a sort
of an explanation for it you know what
because it was about random graphs so we
had to write some
another paper to go with it to explain
the concepts
unfortunately
uh the whole thing was sort of wrong
um
because uh
i didn't put the date on this because
riordan and wonky proved that in spite
of these experiments of six six million
uh they proved that er explosive
percolation happened with probability
tending to zero
okay so it's a sort of um
what's it called
it's a sort of lesson that you know you
you have to make you have to make if
you're doing numerical experiments n has
to be really big
okay
so you know you can't always believe
your eyes
okay
okay so all right let's tend to what
time am i supposed to finish
on the hour it's got 10 minutes so i'm
trying to remember what's next um
maybe i'll
i'll come back to this
oh yeah i'll do this now look at some
algorithmic questions
okay
and then i'll come back to the cover
time stuff bro
maybe
okay so we already we saw what a
matching is this is this is in fact this
is the same slide that appeared about
for her half an hour ago right
um
and so the algorithm so edmunds uh so
the big paper by edmonds is 65 um gave
an algorithm for finding the largest
matching in a graph not just a random
graph in a graph
but uh carbon simpson in 81
are proposed the following algorithm for
finding a largest matching okay so the
algorithm i mean okay there's a lot of
stuff here what basically algorithm says
if you have a you look at your graph if
there's a vertex of degree one
you take that vertex and the air you
take the edge that contains that vertex
and you stick it in your matching you
take away the two and throw away the two
vertices
and you continue
okay and then okay so eventually you
might end up well here's
you might end up with a graph
here we go so we look at
uh yeah just see this
whoops
yeah so this has degree one so i took it
okay i keep going
i keep going
ah so i end up here and the graph this
is the end of phase one
there are no vertices of degree one
um so now i don't know what to do
so i just pick a random edge
okay
and then i'm back i found myself with
vertices of degree one and i just keep
going
and it worked out quite well this time
right
okay so the analysis of this algorithm
comes up with a very surprising
um threshold phenomenon
okay so phase one ends and phase two
begins the first time that there are no
vertices of degree one
and so and phase one
you don't make any mistakes you're
allowed to take those edges and the
phase one edges are are correct in the
sense that there is if you take an edge
that's incident with the vertices degree
one there is some maximum matching that
contains that edge so there's no problem
okay
uh
so what they prove so so carbon ships
analyze the graph when
when you've got a linear number of edges
p is constant over n
and then so we did some more work on it
in fact really we shouldn't put this in
at this in this talk
uh
so let's just ignore the mo stuff right
so there's a really nice
argument was that there's a sharp change
of behavior
round about c equals e where e is the
basis of natural logarithms you know
2.71 et cetera right so i was thinking
to myself like e is the most common
letter
in the english alphabet but you never
get a threshold at e
so and the result was that if c is less
than e
then phase one ends with
very few vertices little low end
vertices
and if c is bigger than e
then with high probability uh phase one
ends with omega so you get a giant
component sort of thing after phase one
and then you keep munching away
and
phase two ends
uh isolates so it's so the algorithm is
sort of asymptotically optimal
okay it doesn't make many mistakes
okay here's some sort of proof about
that but i'm going to skip that
okay so now
i'm going to go back to the cover time
so
so it's often been stated that randomly
drinks so okay so the problem is now
you're looking for hard problems to so
and you're looking for hard random
problems
and it's sort of often been stated that
the hard random problems come at these
thresholds
okay and there's a lot of empirical
evidence for this but i think the first
hard
evidence came from a paper of alan's sly
um
so what is the problem
what is that problem
so um so given a graph g
and we define z of lambda to be the sum
over the independent sets
of lambda raised to the size of that set
and the problem is to estimate z of
lambda
okay
and so what alan proved was that
there isn't any um f prize for
estimating
z of lambda
unless np equals rp and this was under
some
in some range of lambda which i think
has been improved dramatically since now
but anyway so it was a proof that at
some random threshold our things
actually do get hard
okay so let me finish i'll go back to
put the edges back in the graph
okay
okay so
so just let me just mention one thing
about random walk
okay so given a graph
um
a random walk is you put a token
somewhere and it starts to move randomly
about the graph
okay so here's the token it's going
randomly about the graph
and so here's our
i'm going to mention one question about
this but actually there are slides here
about
a very surprising result about this
thing called cutoff um it's a bit
technical so i will skip it
um here's a less technical
notion
so if you do a random walk so you've got
you're on this graph and you're doing
this random walk and you're wandering
around
um
so the vacant set
is the set of vertices that you haven't
visited
okay so they might ask questions well
you can if you want you can ask
questions about the structure of the
vacant set
okay so we let gamma of t
denote the subgraph of g induced by the
vacancy
so the question okay so go back
so the question you want to ask is so
you know you start out with some so we
were working on random regular graphs
and you know you're starting out with a
graph which is connect with high
probability it's connected
and this and this little and imagine
this little creature sort of eating up
the graph
it's wandering around eating it up
and
um
and the quest and then eventually it's
going to eat up the whole thing
and your question is like uh will they
will
as you eat a lot of the graft will it
fall to pieces
so the question is or when will it fall
to pieces
and
uh so we were able to prove then it's
like a reverse of the erdos rini process
so on a random our regular graph at some
precise time you can say
up to time t star in fact you know one
minus epsilon t star up to that time
there will be a
a big chunk left okay imagine some
little worm going through a piece of
cheese and it's wandering around eating
meat and eating as long as he doesn't as
long as time hasn't uh gone on too far
there will be a big lump of cheese in it
but if you go past this threshold then
the thing falls to pieces and all the
other all the
other components are of well once you go
past this the thing falls to bits and
all the components are a size order
login
okay and
and the argument is basically quite not
difficult because
in a random regular graph if you use the
right model um after you've walked
around for a bit the vacant set is a
random graph itself
if i know it's degree sequence it's a
random graph with that degree sequence
and i can work out the degree sequence
and then i can just apply the more
malloy and read criterion so that tells
me exactly what's going
on okay so i think
okay i think i'll stop there
okay thank you very much
faces
oh my oh actually so um
my favorite craftsman open problem is
you take a random graph with constant n
edges
are now the constant is strictly bigger
than one and a half
and you make the condition that the
minimum degree is at least three
this is
a little bit technical and um you would
like to prove that this graph has is
hamiltonian
okay so we know that if you um
so what we know about this question is
if
if c is at least 10
then it is hamiltonian
and
if c is exactly three over two
it's hamiltonian because if c is exactly
three over two it's a random regular
graph
but if it's like one point six n and
your conditional minimum degree three
i don't know it probably is but i can't
prove it that's the problem
and the matching stuff has been solved
that's doable if you say you want to
match you say matt random graph minimum
degree
2 cn edges
c has to be uh
one
no two sorry c has to be two
you need an edges
in degree two
you think
yeah that's it
oh come on
no never
okay
okay
you